[Music]
you
I'm getting on the plane is the long day
already for my sister's bride shower
baby shower not for my sister and to
this McKinley
[Music]
hey everybody we made it home finally
and now guess who's in the car with me
honey break free the pharmacy Jessica
why
yeah I live one it's a GoPro we're on
our way to get what's this rides made
dress for Brie's wedding I'm about to go
get it Taylor - Taylor altered the same
I think Taylor is for guy know why do I
what I'm going to suit tailored yeah
dress hemmed or altered I think that
might be wrong I don't know they'll
correct us okay well he will thankfully
follow it took it together my nails
oh the Tiffany's teal and then what else
are we doing today break do you know
it's Veda vlog every day in April I'm
probably there's something for every
freaking my edges in vlog everyday
period because it's silly it was just
like August this is the same thing for
August it is yes a beta you know every a
month you vlog every day I'm not sure
April August I'm not sure I don't even
like to say that I'm doing it because
what do you think you're doing sir get
all over so after we do this then we're
gonna go to the mall do a little bit of
shopping I'm going to return my iPhone
se because surprise surprise I'm keeping
my iPhone 6 where people are they
allowed to see your bridesmaid dresses
or is that like okay yeah see it yeah
yeah look how pretty are you excited for
your big day I think Brees dressed it's
very exciting this we gave me a breeze
bridal shower so stay tuned for that fun
Jewish
sorry what
Tony D sent us a toy boy this app sexier
you let's check it out my Dhoni has been
relieved Oh My glob we got voice that
your voice I always used to sleep with
my socks on seriously
doesn't you pack no I'm playing my game
called me Dumbo dentist movie is totally
Mars Odyssey excellent adventure
actually stuff that is my voice is it I
knew it
beetlejuice ghostbusters fellows action
Europe machinist Robocop Corddry they
like base off your own toys you know
I'm just playing my game well brace shop
you have fun break
yup uh yeah that's really right it's
okay
yellow doesn't look good on Maddy
Oh for you I'll give them the fun you
look good flesh with your hair color
nice tan
hi you're great
I'd be a really great beauty guru
Cornell did a little shopping freeze
looking and picking out some wedding
makeup getting down to the wire
oh my gosh
pretty go through our foundation brush
big fan of the Bobby Brown ones but I
think that's my favorite powder brush
well you know let's tell Yuri stopping
for wedding jewelry and I saw some
things that I think really might go nice
with her dress further about these over
here come up like this frog would they
give with your dress
I need serious help I'm fine seriously
helping Oh be perfect I would wear that
in a second I would definitely wear that
with my wedding dress you don't think so
and like I do it I think you would I
think I would do it set mines gonna be
wedding sweatpants
do you like my yoga dress my wedding
sweats oh they'll be white
hey remember yesterday we're talking
about Veda which is vlog every day in
April guess what it's log every day in
April and guess what I didn't do
yesterday log all day I didn't post the
video yet oh this is gonna be a four
part video like every other day it's
like a vlog every other day we're not
really sure so we're off to pick up
brianne's cookies and her cake for her
bridal shower tomorrow and I'm like my
eyes are like watering because it's so
windy outside time rode with that hey I
put the address in you don't I don't
know where it's taking you cake cookies
pinyon or pinata
Weejun e yeah is that weird yeah that's
so weird
just use like oh I heard some bridal
shower games and some things to bring
and
the next day shows up a pinata rises and
move into motion before you doing you
don't have to yell or do in a pinata the
next day a helium balloon tank arrived
right and then I'm on my friends we're
asking if there's also going to be pony
ride on from his bridal shower and
quarter summer mile
this is more like carnival I wish there
was but that I did not get a pony ride
it did allow something that you wanted
we can just go and have it at a petting
zoo be honest with you we'll just do
that though time to pick up the cake
multiple cakes there's Brees bridal
shower cake I'm also getting a birthday
cake because my family want to celebrate
my birthing again 9,000 cookies of the
car chocolate over bacon think you're
gonna have to see it you're gonna have
to see it come see it I definitely saw
it you oh my gosh that is so funny
do you like a hilarious it's perfect
someone got a Barbie pink
that's yours only I love it so much
oh my gosh that's hilarious it says oh
my gosh everything to myself we're just
all we have that's great thank you so
cool it look nicer than the picture
I turned do they look so much better
the process of trying to get this in
here and a little bit of a struggle is
too scary cuz that's a little scary yeah
there's cakes and cookies absolutely
everywhere berry so I just got into bed
tomorrow's breeze big bridal shower days
so I need to get to bed early and
prepare for all of the fun festivities
tomorrow I'm sure I'll vlog all of the
fun tomorrow so you can see Bri everyone
wish her in the comments below a happy
bridal shower day and a good luck on her
wedding which is coming up in a month
and a half crazy all right can I see you
later bye
[Music]